Let's talk about the Fox News presidency.
The Donald Trump presidency can in a sense
be called the Fox News presidency because
we know that Donald Trump, uh, mostly watches
Fox News.
We know that Donald Trump will often tweet,
uh, in relation to or get involved in topics
that come up during Fox News programs, including
Fox and friends, their morning show, which
seems to be a favorite of Donald Trump's.
And it's happened many times that atopic Trump
hasn't talked about before will be discussed
on Fox and friends in the morning.
And then suddenly five minutes later, 10 minutes
later, Donald Trump is tweeting about it and
he's getting involved in it.
We then subsequently learned that there's
actually more to it because not only is Donald
Trump's sort of agenda being set in a sense
by Fox and friends in the morning, Donald
Trump we learned is regularly speaking privately
to Fox News.
Propagandists Sean Hannity, they'll often
speak at night Hannity, sort of putting Trump
to bed as the case may be in practice.
And Sean Hannity all of a sudden has significant
influence on the president and on this sort
of a agenda setting power that is given to
a lot of the people that Donald Trump chooses
to allow into his inner circle.
It's getting even worse though.
There is now a daily beast article which reveals
that Fox News host, Tucker Carlson, who of
course has lost many advertisers over his
xenophobic rants on the channel in the last
year or so.
Tucker Carlson is privately advising Donald
Trump, uh, on topics of foreign policy.
It appears specifically related to the Middle
East and most recently it's specifically related
to Iran.
What on earth does Tucker Carlson know about
Iran?
You might ask, and that's a good question,
although it appears that Tucker Carlson may
actually be advising Donald Trump in the right
direction when it comes to the topic of Iran.
And I'll get to that in a second.
Um, you'll maybe to set the stage, uh, um,
uh, remember that Donald Trump's Iran policy
has been completely abortive, abortive rather.
So if he's been influenced by Tucker Carlson
already, it's possible that Tucker Carlson
has been guiding him astray.
And in general, when I hear that Trump is
taking foreign policy advice from the guy
who lost advertisers for lamenting that the
United States as it becomes less white is
less American.
I'm concerned, but, and this is a big but
in this particular case, reports are that
Tucker Carlson has been telling Donald Trump
not to take military action against Iran,
which seems to be the exact opposite of what
people around Donald Trump, like Warhawk national
security adviser John Bolton would be telling
Donald Trump to do.
There is a serious, uh, a senior administration
official who told the daily beast that Tucker
Carlson has been bashing Donald Trump's more
hawkish administration members.
And in fact, uh, on Monday, Tucker Carlson
actually said on his Fox News program that
the intelligence around Iran and the recent
oil tanker attack in the Gulf of Oman is reminding
him of the bogus intelligence that led up
to the war in Iraq back in 2003.
And this is not surprising.
I mean, Tucker Carlson has talked about this
before.
This clip I'm going to play for you is from
almost a year ago, and you will hear Tucker
Carlson saying that a war with Iran would
destroy Donald Trump's presidency.
He's been saying this for awhile.
We are moving toward, however slowly some
kind of confrontation with Iran.
Now that should worry everybody, but it should
especially be of concern to anyone who supported
the president.
Your president Trump decides to go to war
with Iran.
It will destroy his presidency.
Just as the Iraq war destroyed the presidency
of his Republican predecessor, George W. Bush
attacking Ron is not like intervening in Libya
or Syria or even like invading Iraq.
It entails far greater risk and much higher
costs.
We're Tucker is wrong, is that while in an
academic and historical sense, the Iraq war
did destroy George W Bush's presidency.
He still got reelected while that Iraq war
was going on and the talking point of we shouldn't
change horses.
Midstream was one of the arguments that realistically
got George W. Bush some more votes.
So while it's true, that war with Iraq destroyed
bushes, legacy electorally, it wasn't bad
for him.
And electorally Donald Trump going to war
with Iran might also not be a bad thing for
him.
But ultimately, Tucker Carlson is right here,
and I have no problem saying it.
I mean, listen, if Tucker Carlson is pushing
Donald Trump to stay out of Iran, that's good.
It's disgusting that xenophobe Tucker Carlson
has influence in this way and that he seems
to have been brought into Donald Trump's very
vile and disgusting inner circle, which includes
people like Sean Hannity in addition now to
Tucker Carlson.
Carlson is regularly wrong about endless things.
It's pathetically embarrassing that Donald
Trump is so influenced by what goes on at
Fox News Day in and day out.
And the agenda setting power that Fox News
and its hosts have gotten is disturbing to
anyone who is clear thinking and rational.
But, but I don't want Donald Trump going into
Iran and if Tucker Carlson is telling Donald
Trump not to go into Iran, that's a good thing.
There's just lots of other people who know
much more and are otherwise much more correct
on world issues.
Then Tucker Carlson, who would also be telling
Donald Trump, you shouldn't go into Iran.
And by the way, Donald Trump is now insisting
that Iran abide by the Iran nuclear deal,
which he bailed out of months ago.
And we are going to talk about that a little
bit later on in the program.
Make sure you are following the David Pakman
show on Instagram, uh, at David Pakman show
is our handle on Instagram.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Dot.
Pacman.
I just surpassed a, I believe it's 50,000
followers on Instagram and I would love for
you to make it 50,001 follow me on Instagram
at David.
Dot.
Pacman quick break,
much, much more coming up
after this,